when one hears the names shown and jump
what immediately springs to mind would
probably be timeless classics featuring
action heroes and imaginable powers and
some of the most explosive fights in
anime history young people have always
been enthralled by the magazine's
various treats maybe by following
Luffy's journey across the sea
seeing Naruto grow up to become a legend
or watching deku follow the footsteps of
the greats
today we won't be discussing such heroic
tales
trust me it's as dark as it gets in the
promised never land despite only having
12 episodes to work with this anime is
chock full of moments that will either
tear your heart out drive you to tears
or fire you up with adrenaline
[Music]
[Music]
different
Oh
coming in at number 10 is the moment
that the main team the trio of Emma
Norman and Ray is formed after seeing
Connie's death at the hands of the
demons in the true purpose of grace
Fieldhouse Emma and Norman hatch a plan
to escape they're soon joined by ray and
after much convincing an alliance is
formed this seems important because it
sets the tone for the dynamics among the
three main protagonists as well as their
philosophies and key personality traits
holding on two different sets of ideals
the trio begin to hatch the plan to
escape certain death at the hands of the
demons come on
boku mo mo mo Jogi Anaya can then it's
email fit for plug in either
okay never nice key militant Donna lay
at number nine we have the reveal of a
traitor among the group of course not
every escape plan goes smoothly
especially one as intricate as this
things get a bit rocky early for a
moment number nine when the kids suspect
that one of the children in grace for
your house is working as a spy for
Isabella they decide to test two prime
suspects dawn and Gilda by sharing with
them the unbelievable secret of grace
for your house they set a trap for them
and towards the end of episode four the
traitor gets revealed in a shocking
twist of events though the traitors
revealed to be none other than Rey who
gets caught thanks to Norman's savvy
strategy in an even bigger twist Rey
reveals that he's a double agent he's
been planning his escape all this time
and in order to do so has had to gain
Isabella's trust now that's one hell of
a wild card if we've ever seen one
coming up next for moment number eight
is the scene where dawn and Gilda
stumble upon Isabella's secret room in
episode 6 it remains one of the more
suspenseful scenes in the series as the
two kids begin inspecting the room the
scene has it all ominous ambience a
chilling atmosphere and an overall setup
which has the audience wary of a
possible scare the scene culminates with
the two children finding out what really
happened to the children that leave the
orphanage needless to say the impulsive
dawn doesn't take to the truth kindly
the outburst filled fall out where dawn
and Gilda officially joined the main
team is also something to look out for
[Music]
number seven is sister Crone's of final
moments episode 2 introduces us to
sister crone almost immediately
are three main conspirators grow weary
of this helper while she proves to be a
tough opponent she mostly spends time
behind the scenes revealing a strained
relationship with Isabella it doesn't
take long for her to act on her true
ambition leading her to propose an
alliance with the children vying for the
position of grace Fieldhouse's mama she
hopes that the children will help her
take down Isabella unfortunately for her
though Isabella outwits her and easily
shuts down her plans even if she's shown
herself to be a manipulative antagonist
it's hard not to feel sorry for her
during her last moments in episode 8
especially with the flashbacks the music
and seeing her fight for survival until
the very end Taku this
[Music]
economic so me tightness a car you push
casa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number six in the list is the
magnificent display of wits courtesy of
Isabella imagine an overly intricate
plan that you and a bunch of friends
come up with that's foolproof and
perfect then comes this detestable woman
and in a flash everything goes poof the
majority of episode 8 just a bag of
despair waiting to be spilled as in the
span of one episode isabella manages to
get rid of crone outsmart the kids get
one step ahead of them and break Emma
both figuratively and literally all that
sent ups gone in less than an episode in
magnificent fashion while the children
thought they were pulling the strings it
turns out that they were all in the palm
of her hand instead episode 8 truly
shows us what kind of terrifying
opponent Isabella really is it's at this
point that we all know that she's not an
opponent to be messed with and that the
children are nothing but helpless kids
in the face of such adversary
Oh
no my tech rep I own a Mina destiny
megawatt me Mohammed Amin Amin Garnica
but a sanada-san unity Oh No
[Music]
Oh at number five we have the trio's
last-ditch attempts in saving Norman
right after she's foiled the children's
escape plan Isabella drops a bomb on
everyone that Norman is to be shipped
out immediately
the rest of the main protagonists
refused to accept the impending doom of
their friend Emma and Rhea start
thinking of ways to save Norman this
opens up scenes where we learn more
about raid we already know that he's
worked as a double agent both as a spy
for Isabella and on the side of the
children what we don't know is just how
long Ray's been doing it the answer is
revealed in episode 9 where we discover
that he knew everything all along
amazingly ever since he found out the
truth about grace for your house Ray's
been planning his escape even all those
gifts he gathered from Isabella allowed
him to create a device built to destroy
the trackers on the children precisely
something that can save Norman for the
two kids they're all getting out of this
mess together whatever it takes the
opponents have shown themselves to be
tough but maybe just maybe Norman would
get to live to fight another day
[Applause]
today dick I you know man
next up at number four it's the scene
where Norman gets shipped out and the
fallout this is arguably one of the most
heartbreaking moments in the series
having decided to accept his fate Norman
doesn't go along with Emma and rays
escape plan and returns to grace-filled
house he made the decision to prioritize
the others and allow them a better
chance of escape rather than taking a
shot at keeping himself alive Norman
made the ultimate sacrifice is truly
heart-wrenching to see Norman go
even after entire episodes of others
planning his escape
Norman simply brushes everything aside
in an attempt to avoid jeopardizing the
escape of those left behind with this
the brains of the team finally makes his
exit and walks into certain doom or does
he'd left without Norman the children
give up and are now permanently doomed
to wait for the inevitable despair
overcomes even ray who's shown himself
to be quite tenacious in the previous
episodes however in the face of utter
despair Emma reveals to the audience one
of the most iconic shots of her face in
the series a smile of grim determination
she's not about to give up on saving
everyone not now not ever
[Music]
Oh Gaga chemotherapeutic organoid er the
tiny mystery night at number three we
have raised sacrifice on the night when
he's supposed to be shipped out ray
pulls out one final gambit you see he's
been planning the escape for so long
with one consideration he's not part of
the escape that's right the stoic and
seemingly least altruistic member of the
main trios final plan is to sacrifice
himself by setting the house on fire
taking himself along with it that would
distract Isabela enough to allow Emma
and the others to escape
scratch that thing I said earlier about
Norman pulling the ultimate sacrifice
this one definitely tops that and it's
coming from Ray to race crazed
expressions and lions as well as the
accompanying music make this one scene
that you should watch the anime
adaptation for corridor unit I know Roy
tidiness a doctor oh my rotten chicken
was to get honest boy
[Applause]
second in the list is the initial reveal
of grace for your houses secret you guys
have probably seen this coming for our
number two moment in the promised
Netherland I doubt this any stronger
seen for new viewers than episode ones a
big reveal of what really happens to the
kids who knew that instead of being
adopted the kids that get shipped out
are actually food for the demons seeing
Connie's dead bodies shocking and
unnerving enough but seeing the demons
who are terrifying in their own right
collude with Isabella is another the
peaceful world of grace Fieldhouse gets
turned upside down in one powerful
sequence of events it's at this point
where everyone knows that the promised
Neverland isn't going to be just another
shown in series that you typically find
in shown and jump
[Music]
finally at number one in the list we
have the climactic escape operation talk
about an escape operation of epic
proportions
so race survives thanks to Norman's
planning of course using Emma as his
proxy after his departure his legacy
lives on in the form of The Great Escape
what makes this such an awesome moment
of triumph is the fact that the escape
was made possible by everyone working
together seeing everyone play a role and
seeing the fruit of everyone's growth
makes this truly a worthwhile payoff for
the whole season we also find out about
Isabella's past in many ways she can be
interpreted as just another victim of
circumstance it was a cruelty of life
that turned her cold she tried and
failed to break the chains of fate yet
the hopes of her young naive self are
carried on in the form of Emma ray and
the rest of the escapees in the end even
Isabella and the demons are finally
outsmarted and outplayed after 12 bleak
and grueling episodes we ultimately end
the season on a bright and hopeful note
with the kids seeing their first sunrise
free from the grim fate that once bound
them
[Music]
sai-san asada and there we have it the
promised neverland's top ten moments
thanks for watching and I hope that this
video helped you recall some of the most
epic heartbreaking and dramatic moments
in the animes run don't forget to
comment below on your favorite moments
from the show leave a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already for more
anime related content I'll see you next
time on Vinnie tube
[Music]